the drafts Thursday night think about a
biggest night of your life and you got a
FaceTime from the [ __ ] Denver Broncos
we select you with a nice big dude you
dressed up like an [ __ ] can I only
have ten people in your house just in
suits yeah that's gonna be awkward huh
hey
yeah wonder jobber Oh go first don't you
think no doubt no doubt but then it gets
dicey after that cuz to a tire boss or
whatever the [ __ ] the Alabama
quarterback they think he's gonna drop
the 6-2 the LA Chargers which I hope
happens charges dropped their new you
knees today they did and they are so we
really don't
well they had those new helmets they
drop then people didn't like you happy /
hating on the logo saying it look like a
dick there they are
they just dropped this morning oh pretty
filthy where's the cheer uniforms la was
the first one ram brain that's a
cheerleader on their team the guy a
woman LA Rams were the first ones out
with male cheerleader they have two male
cheerleaders do they have you seen I'm
Chappelle no did you think you were
cheerleader oh if you see these boys
okay [ __ ] world champ over here what
does that Star Wars yeah that Jar Jar
Binks I don't know I'm asking you guys
yeah these are the boys
good luck Chappell how bad you want to
be in the NFL or no apple-bobbing dance
they're dancers yeah they dancers dog
they can't do what I do I don't think
you can do what they do we give up
whatever huh oh yeah you better stop
meeting man if you want to dance
[Laughter]
drug-induced is nice bra that dude is
nothing either boys hit that yeah both
made the team hey do you feel a
disadvantage moszer was or was there
also gay man that were cheerleading when
you were cheerleader dude [ __ ]
cheerleading's like
90% gay okay more than that though you
know 99% you don't think 90% isn't
enough game to help you no I know but I
feel like he's being modest it is the
only straight cheerleader I've ever met
Wow no my uh a lot of us I got a cousin
in law do this got Jamie and he probably
he trained us Topanga Canyon he might be
a damn sex offender as well he was a
male cheerleader for Alabama named
straight uh yeah he's straight but he's
okay mama night if it's if it got if
Ozark went to a fifth season he would be
gay like it just depends but I'll say
this man my friend Cheyenne was a
cheerleader for the Chargers but do you
think that there was an unfair advantage
for gay men with cheerleading what do
mean like where they did a little more
sugar in the tank yeah they got more
sugar in the tank or where they better
at it that's a good question I mean I
don't know that's a tough question have
you have you seen the the Netflix
documentary chair yeah yeah I cheered at
the rival school I used to compete
against all really do oh yeah no Monica
since it's like 2007 you don't know much
your career works at a JUCO school at a
Duke coaster no like competitive cheer
like world champion they have world
championships for just competitive your
school your whole squad was the world
champions are just you the John Henry a
[ __ ] cheerleading yeah they call me
yeah they used to say I was a little
Bron James bro yeah LeBron James yeah no
not LeBron I'd say they used to say he
was the Gary Payton of Cheerilee bases
they use the Latrell Sprewell
cheerleader but but they do totally
different than what I did like I was
like lifting in like tumbling lifting
what they did on the show cheer to them
yeah you were like more like them yes
not stay on that team but when that team
yes they just didn't interview on but
what about here's what I'm asking you
them man y'all right y'all not evading
the question
I did well what's the two gay men have
an advantage yes when it comes to
cheerleading because many more sugar in
the tank yeah like if you saw a gay man
come on do you think gay dudes that suck
okay cheer at you at you
Chuck's you I never seen that I don't
work there as well but um but yeah they
just yeah I mean wait why was this much
but here's the thing know if a get is a
gay man a better chillier than a
straight man that's what I'm asking cuz
I'm thinking if I'm a straight man and
I'm a cheerleader mmm I am one and not
the other I was pretty damn good well
are you the best that was pretty damn
good the best though could you still
compete at a high level
yeah one percent [ __ ] yeah dude and I'm
unless on my computer was 2013 bro come
on now that's not that long that was
seven let's go you got both of his knees
replace do it and you'll watch my videos
you'll see mine I've seen you do back
flips and [ __ ] I'm just saying I see
guys your continue to do it and they're
getting paid what I'm not getting paid
you just solve the boys we just solved
for that Oh a lot of money for that
[ __ ] team they get $50 a game thank
you
right there two more dollars in
chapelier okay really really doing
comedy yeah that's again bringing less
fighting it's probably the same alright
he's gonna choke him like this realm
yeah dude
I'll be stamp and gun
[Music]
the king nothing
[Music]